let's say that we had a cube let me draw
the cube here so we have a cube and we
know that the volume of this cube is
equal to 512 cubic centimeters so my
question to you is what are the
dimensions of this cube so what is what
is this length going to be what is this
I guess you could say depth and what is
this height going to be and we know it's
a cube so these are all going to be
equal and so like always encourage you
to pause the video and try to figure it
out well let's call let's call this
length X if that's X then this is going
to be X and then this is X as well so if
the volume is 512 cubic centimeters that
means that the that means that x times X
times X is going to be equal to 512 is
going to be equal to 512 or we could say
that X to the third power is equal to
512 or we could say that X is equal to
the cube root of 512 so what's the cube
root of 512 and the easiest way I can
think about doing this if I don't have a
calculator is to just try to do a prime
factorization of this by hand so that's
what I'm going to attempt to do so let's
see does 2 go into 512 sure 512 even so
this is going to be 2 times let's see
256 yep 2 times 256 256 that's also
divisible by 2 that's 2 times 128 which
is also divisible by 2 that's 2 times 64
which is also divisible by 2 that's 2
times 32 let's see I can keep going
that's 2 times 16 which is 2 times 2
times 8 which is 2 times 4 which is 2
times 2 so 512 that's the same thing as
2 to the let's see you have 1 2 3 4 5 6
7 8 9 that's 2 to the 9th power but what
we care about is what times itself times
itself is
equal what number if I have three of
them and I multiply them together get us
to 512 and to think about that we could
say look I have nine numbers here so let
me divide it into three groups so if
this is one group and this is the next
group and then this is the next group
right over here we could say that 512 is
the same thing as 2 times 2 times 2
which is 8 times 2 times 2 times 2 which
is 8 times 2 times 2 times 2 so 512 is
the same thing as 8 to the third power
so we could say that we could say that X
I'll do it over here X is equal to the
cube root of instead of writing 512
instead of writing 512 I could write 8
to the third power now what's the cube
root of something to the third power was
just going to be this something so X X
is going to be equal to 8 so if the
volume here is 512 cubic centimeters
each dimension is going to be 8
centimeters so X is equal to 8
centimeters this is equal to 8
centimeters I'm just writing the unit's
now this is equal to 8 centimeters and
we're done but if you didn't know
offhand that 8 to the third power is 512
this is a reasonable way of coming to
that conclusion
anyway hopefully that helped